c'est ici qu'on vote les lois pour le
peuple mais où le peuple n'est pas
vraiment bien de
ces excités ce sont ces militants contre
le mariage pour tous dans les tribunes
le jour du vote de la loi en 2013
soudain une banderole réclamant un
référendum et déployer les ennemis de la
démocratie n'ont rien à faire dans
l'hémicycle
banderole cris tout cela est interdit au
public de l'assemblée nationale mais
dont l'hémicycle les militants qui se
glissent parmi les spectateurs imposent
leur loi entrée en scène des
intermittents du spectacle en 2003 acte
1 la question celle d'un député ps à
propos des intermittents monsieur
aillagon acte 2 la réponse non celle du
ministre mais celles d'une partie du
public
3 intermittents tente de lire un texte
acte 3 les accusations
le mot voyou est lâché la droite accuse
la gauche d'un coup monté ça s'engueule
s'envoient des noms d'oiseaux
l'intrusion de militants brise le cadre
police et de l'assemblée ces images sont
d'ailleurs si rare qu'à chaque fois
elles font l'ouverture du jt un incident
rare mais sans gravité un inconnu a
réussi à s'approcher de jean pierre
raffarin un petit moment de panique il a
été attrapé par les pieds par les
huissiers ça paraît fou mais en 2002 cet
homme s'approche au plus près du premier
ministre jean pierre raffarin plus de
peur que de mal l'homme voulait juste
lui remettre une coupe sportive mais
preuve en est la sécurité n'est jamais
infaillible ce matin déjà une dizaine de
militants de greenpeace était parvenu à
grimper sur les toits de l'assemblée
nationale en 2009 après avoir pris
d'assaut le toit du palais-bourbon
d'autres militants de greenpeace en
outre dans l'assemblée et tout d'un coup
un déboulé de gendarmes dans les
couloirs du palais bourbon des gendarmes
sur les dons car à l'intérieur de
l'hémicycle
une militante est en train de descendre
en rappel dont les tribunes des députés
une banderole est rapidement déployée où
l'on peut lire aux actes monsieur le
président à droite c'est la colère
l'indignation
ambiance volcanique
alors que les députés verts encourage
les perturbateurs le nom la militante
descendu en rappel est l'invitée du 13
heures de france 2 on vous a accusé hier
d'utiliser des méthodes fascistes je
cite et de violer la démocratie qu'est
ce que vous répondez à cela je crois que
bien au contraire on ne viole pas la
démocratie on a choisi la maison du
peuple pour faire passer un message la
maison du peuple un endroit stratégique
devant lequel convergent
nombre de manifestations et qui à chaque
fois est largement aux protégés par les
forces de l'ordre mais le temps des
grandes entreprises y ont semble
derrière nous jusqu'à la prochaine
[Musique]